let's go [ __ ] scumbags I love this on
great song I always wondered to be the
mind was he make a sound
well now you know
welcome back boys how did we enjoy our
sabbatical it was very relaxing I
masturbated a lot I receive very serious
allegations and of assault corruption
charges against you are you trying a
promise man no now what have we learned
bribery corruption bad yes progress has
been made memories fun of us [ __ ]
over a Christian juggler
what happened to the driver he got away
with the money
close to a mil a million dollars a
million dollars a million whose money
our money the whole thing was planned by
the British dude named James Mangan what
can find him what am i hugging bill now
hope you bear hey shorty where can we
find James Mangan Oh God you mean I've
been weird the way I put the report man
I'm sorry I didn't mean Oh sick
Oh plotting these things anymore
you ain't got a good script you ain't
got [ __ ] ups halo 5 guardians Assassin's
Creed chronicles true oh that's great
that's great I don't know I have no idea
what that [ __ ] is you could be speaking
[ __ ] Swahili now with knowing better
grand theft auto